-My next guest is
a very talented actress
starring on the hit
television series "Bridgerton."
Season 1 is
streaming now on Netflix.
Here's Phoebe Dynevor,
everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness! Hello!
Phoebe Dynevor!
-Hi!
-Hello and welcome.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for coming on.
It's your first time
on our show.
-Yes. I'm so happy to be here.
Thank you so much for having me.
-I want to --
-I'm your biggest fan.
-Alright,
well, right back at you.
Alright, here we go.
I do -- I want to
talk to you about "Bridgerton,"
but I also want to say we
just had Lin-Manuel Miranda
out here on the show,
and I know that
you're a big fan of Lin and...
-[ Breathes deeply ]
Can we just talk about
"Hamilton" this whole interview?
Because I'm the biggest fan
of Lin-Manuel ever.
-Wait, wait. Hold on a second.
But, you know,
there's Lin, who was here,
but then there's me,
who is here, you know?
-Yeah, both of you
in the same room is crazy.
I don't know what
to do with myself right now.
But Lin-Manuel --
"Hamilton" literally got me
and my family through lockdown.
We would play it
every single day.
We watched the theater version
a million times
and we can sing every song.
So, yeah, "Hamilton"
is the best, the best.
I cannot wait to see
"In the Heights."
-Oh, get ready.
Get ready.
-Oh, my gosh.
-No, you won't even believe --
This Thursday,
you won't even believe it.
Get ready. It pays off.
But people will say the same
thing for you, by the way,
because you got us
through quarantine.
We all got to experience
you with "Bridgerton"
and we all --
That was a moment.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a TV moment.
And that's amazing.
And it came out of nowhere.
I had no idea.
We were just looking
for something to watch,
and everyone was like, "I'm in.
It's 'Downton Abbey'
but spicier."
I don't know what it was,
but we didn't know what it was.
And it was so great.
And I always love a good story,
as anyone does,
but the story of you getting
cast is interesting to me,
because I heard that you were
almost ready to just kind of
give up on acting in L.A.
for a little bit,
and you go,
"Eh, it's not working out.
I'm going to go back
to England."
Is that true?
-Yeah. I had been --
It was kind of crazy.
I've been living in L.A.
for about nine months
and I was kind of at that point
where I was ready to go home,
sort of throw in the towel,
and see the fam for a bit.
And then I got a call saying,
"Can you come in and read with
Regé next week?"
And I was like "Oh, God.
Well, that's annoying, 'cause
I've got to move my flight."
So I was like,
"I hope it pays off."
-Yeah. "I don't want to do this
and get rejected."
Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah, exactly.
And then --
Yeah, and then, the next day,
they were like,
"Netflix will pay
for your flight back to London,
because you've got to be in
rehearsals on Monday."
-That's what I'm talking about!
-So it did pay off.
-Yes! That's the story
that you want.
I love that!
-Yeah. Yeah.
-When did you recognize that
you and Regé-Jean had chemistry?
Because Regé-Jean
has been on our show,
and I had chemistry with
Regé-Jean.
-Yeah, it's hard not to.
-Yeah, but you two together,
it's like, "What is going on?"
When did you guys realize it?
Was it rehearsal or was it --
Did you do a scene and you go,
"That's pretty good, guys."
[ Laughter ]
-I think you never know,
but we both had
dance rehearsals together
and we were both kind of nervous
about the dancing part.
It was the part that
we were both a bit like,
"Oh, can we do this?"
And I remember
we had a few rehearsals,
and one of them got recorded so
we got to watch it back.
And we were like,
"Oh, eye contact
really does a lot of the work."
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah, you felt --
-And dancing.
-Yeah, exactly.
Well, I think it was
brilliantly done.
And we know that he's not
returning for Season 2, but --
A lot of people
were disappointed,
but if you read
the books, which --
or read the books,
which I have not --
So I was going, "Aww!"
And then they go, "No, that's
the way the story goes."
It was never planned for him
to return in Season 2.
Is that correct?
-No, I mean, I think every --
The special thing about
"Bridgerton"
that I think not a lot of
shows really do
is that every season centers
around a different love story.
So, Season 2 is centered around
Anthony, my older brother,
and his sort of coming out
into the season
and finding a match, hopefully.
So, every story centers
around a different relationship.
So, I'm just really excited
to watch the show as an audience
and see what it has
in store for him.
-But you're back and you're
filming Season 2 right now?
-Yeah, yeah.
I've had three days on set.
It's so nice to be back.
-What does it feel like?
-It's such a nice feeling.
Oh, it's the best.
I cried like seven times
when I came back,
'cause so much had happened, you
know, since the first season.
Obviously, COVID
and the show coming out
and just seeing everyone again.
I mean, half of their faces,
for the most part.
But, yeah, it's just so nice.
-Still, I'll take it, yeah.
Well, on behalf of everyone
who actually did
get through quarantine
thanks to you,
I just want to say
thank you very much
for doing what you did.
It was definitely
a big moment for us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I want to show everyone
a clip from Season 1.
Here's Phoebe Dynevor and
Regé-Jean Page in "Bridgerton."
Take a look.
-It would be better
if you refrained
from thinking about me at all.
-It is simply surprising.
-Yes, how ever
is it possible for a lady
to offer anything but a smile
whilst seated beside a duke?
-You regarding subjects
much too...
-Even one of your reputation.
-You are aware of my reputation.
-I'm aware of your friendship
with my eldest brother.
If that were not enough,
I'm also aware of the things
a certain writer
has recently written of you.
Presumptuous?
Clearly.
Arrogant? Most definitely.
You are a rake
through and through.
Tell me I'm wrong.
-Who is to refrain
from thinking about whom again?
-I assure you, I'm anything
but interested in you.
-Good.
-Quite.
-And I anything
but interested in you.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Phoebe Dynevor, everybody!
Season 1 of "Bridgerton"
is streaming now on Netflix.